votre masque va devenir votre plus grand
allié vous allez devoir le porter
obligatoirement dans tous les lieux
publics que vous fréquentez
habituellement dans les restaurants les
bords les commerces de détail mais aussi
dans les transports en commun au gymnase
dans les lieux de culte et dans toutes
les aires communes comme un ascenseur
par exemple devrait même porter votre
marque à l'auberge vous vous direz
passer vos vacances
ça peut paraître simple mais vous
certain que vous portez bien votre
masque me lève toujours - les maires de
m puis si je le touche et je le touche
au moins essayer
comme si je leur aurais je le fais comme
ça j'en ai plusieurs j'en ai acheté dès
le début de la pandémie
je vois du monde qui porte ce genre en
dessous d'une épique ouais c'est pas
bien mais c'est difficile d'être parfait
[Musique]
pour vous éviter les erreurs les plus
communes on a décidé d'aller demander
conseil à une infirmière en prévention
des infections mme harris moore bonjour
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté nous faire
un cours 101 sur le port du masque
première question comment thèse que j'ai
l'install mon masque
la première étape c'est vraiment de
faire un bon lavage de mains on peut le
faire avec une solution à base d'alcool
ou un lavage des mains à l'eau et au
savon c'est suffisant et pourquoi on
fait le lavage des mains c'est parce
qu'on venait porter nos mains à notre
visage
ensuite on prend le masque et on
installe les courroies derrière les
oreilles
ensuite on vient étendre le masque pour
qu'il couvre bien le nom et sous le
menton dernière étape
on vient moulé au niveau du nez le mas
pour qui les pousse bien la forme du
visage
alors le masque une fois installé dans
le visage idéalement nous touche plus on
laisse là tout à fait les erreurs qu'on
voit souvent c'est que les gens vont
venir toucher donc ça ne pas faire aussi
ils vont venir le retirer pour parler ou
aussi skier à ne pas faire c'est
d'installer le masque en le portant sous
le nez ou dans le coup c'est pendant la
journée pour une raison pour nom j'ai dû
l'enlever
où est ce que je le mets mon mac dans un
sac ou une enveloppe surtout pas dans
les poches ou dans la sacoche pour ma
part un masque réutilisables combien de
fois est ce que je peux le porter avant
de devoir le laver et comment je les
lave par la suite idéalement une seule
journée quand on revient à la maison on
le lave à l'eau chaude à la machine et
ensuite on le passe à la sécheuse c'est
pour ça que c'est bien d'en avoir deux
trois pour faire une rotation de tout ce
que vous nous avez dit qu'est ce qu'on
doit retenir absolument à propos du port
du masque il faut bien le manipuler en
n'omettant pas de se laver les mains
avant de le mettre
et après et aussi que ça remplace pour
la distance de 2 mains qu'il faut
respecter entre chaque personne je pense
qu'ensemble on peut faire la différence
marie faure merci beaucoup pour ce
coureur merci ces nouvelles réalités qui
touche tous ceux qui sont âgés de plus
de 12
et la santé publique l'admet le port du
masque c'est un apprentissage pour
plusieurs d'entre nous il faudra le
faire les réfractaires s'exposent à des
amendes qui peuvent aller jusqu'à 6000 $